all right well next now you actually
found this next story drew and it shows
that night life is looking a little
different these days who i'd love a
night out right are you guys in the mood
to go out again have a fun night
i like that i like this spirit yeah i
feel like i'm always alone on my couch i
need to like kibbits with other people
and hear that cheer because it is very
motivating it absolutely is and now it's
a whole new game out there new york
times reports new yorkers are ditching
the clubs and gamifying their hangouts
yeah royal palms in groeness brooklyn
offers wall-to-wall shuffleboard courts
thank you very much i love shuffleboard
uh union hall over in park slope they
have bocce ball i love bocce you love
bocce i do i built a court in my house
it turns out if you have plywood and
some gravel bocce court that's easy it's
so easy and then the uncommons a bar in
the village has an epic board game
collection so you come for the tater
tots stay for the guess who and i in
palm springs there are a bunch of bars
that have like oversized connect four
oversized jenga every saturday i play
bingo
i know like you went to studio 54 i go
to studio connect four
[Laughter]
that's my jam but would you do this play
games in the bar yeah there's actually a
great bar in new york it's like a rec
room it used to be called the fat cat
does anyone has anyone ever been to the
fat cat
yes thank you
we probably saw each other there
what was the fat catwalk it's like a rec
room it's like a concrete basement and
they have shuffleboard and ping pong and
pool tables and board games and there's
like literally the bar is a fridge it's
so cool i think they just changed their
name
um to seller dog i don't know if it's
under new ownership um but i've always
enjoyed
uh activities while partying it's like
instead of just staring at each other
and you know talking which i'm into that
too totally i love an activity so this
story spoke to me as like
gaming is is is now acceptable for night
life and i've always been there and i'm
just like good me too all right next um
as the last three months have shown us
how difficult times are
people will find a way to help each
other so this story really spoke to me
people reports one missouri mom named
wendy farrell sprung into action to help
31 children at an orphanage in ukraine
get safely to poland her journey started
from a personal place because she
adopted a daughter from ukraine in 2013
named alana and that inspired her to
start a non-profit called one you
project dedicated to supporting other
children like her daughter alana yeah
and now wendy and a team from her
non-profit traveled to poland themselves
to welcome the children and help them
get set up with a room and board and
enroll them in school and their new
temporary home this is amazing you think
about what we can do
to help
that's exactly how i felt i saw her
story so if you go to our website at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com and you'd like
to support her we are doing the same
over here and thank you so much
[Music]
you